Serbia is pushing ahead with moves to
join the European Union but Brussels is
so far unimpressed with its reforms my
guest this week visiting Berlin is the
Serbian Prime Minister and a burner
[ __ ] why so little progress on so many
key issues
[Music]
Prime Minister Anna marina beach welcome
to conflict zone thank you very much
thank you for inviting one of the
conditions for Serbia joining the EU is
that you sign a legally binding
agreement on peaceful relations with
Kosovo which declared its independence
in 2008 you've never recognized that
these talks come and go sometimes
they're on sometimes they're off why
should the EU bother with all this
feuding and bilateral disputes that you
have with Kosovo you're too much trouble
for the EU aren't you I think that as
much as our interest is to join the EU I
think the enlargement to cover Balkans
is also in the EU s interest I think
first and foremost European Union is a
peace project and it's a successful one
because we have for the first time in
history a long term peace in Europe will
you say that but they who has made it
clear haven't they they cannot and will
not import bilateral disputes
jean-claude Juncker said it last year
that's pretty clear isn't it it's clear
they're not going to import your dispute
with Kosovo is normal to me I think
that's just natural thing to do I would
ask that if I were the EU as well so
you're not gonna settle this anytime
soon you've admitted that yourself so
there's not really no perspective for
you joining in the in the foreseeable
future is there I would 100% disagree
with you on that point because firstly
the the the soonest possible date for us
to join the EU is 2025 so by 2025 I
think there is a possibility that we
actually sign a long term normalization
agreement with breeched
really it doesn't look like it at the
moment I'm not saying that this will
happen I'm saying that Serbia is
committed to it
it doesn't depend on Serbia alone it
depends also on Pristina as well as on
other allies of ours so I think we're
going into that in the direction of the
EU for me what's important is that we
actually implement all the reforms so
that as a society politically
economically we
become fit for the EU yeah but you say
that and I want to come on to those
reforms real only in a little bit
because the EU is far from happy with
the state of your reforms but but last
week I would also disagree with that in
the enlargement strategy the EU clearly
identified Serbia and Montenegro as
frontrunners I would say that is far
from being this disappointed with us but
the easier is getting fed up with you
and at the Sofia summit in May and later
in London there was a pretty lukewarm
attitude to all six Balkan countries
looking to join the EU no mention of any
timetable for accession and it's a
pretty clear opposition from the French
president Emmanuel macron wasn't that
clear opposite let me let me just say
that I do not think that you have the
right to say that
EU is fed up with us I don't think it's
diplomatic but I don't think you can say
that on behalf of the EU if you was fed
up with us then we would not have any
new chapters opened and we do have new
chapters being constantly opened and
there the trend is that we are going
towards the EU well that's not the
president macro who said what we've seen
over the past 15 years is a path that
has weakened Europe every time we think
of enlarging it and I don't think we do
a service to the candidate countries or
ourselves by having a mechanism that in
a way no longer has rules and keeps
moving towards more enlargement that was
hardly welcoming you with both music and
I agree with President McCrone 100% I do
not think that enlargement in the past
was particularly successful I think they
were likely to be with you can I think
they're likely to be with you and I
think that the consequence of that kind
of accession to the EU is that the
country who's accessing the EU is weaker
because its economy cannot compete it's
agriculture cannot compete the
suffer from a huge brain drain and the
EU gets weaker so why don't you put your
membership on hold stop taking the EU
funds sort out the bilateral problems
with Kosovo you know the other what do
you mean how many funds how much money
do you get from you yeah you're getting
hundreds of millions we are getting much
less than that we're getting
pre-accession funds in the pre-accession
funds are much smaller than for the
funds that the EU member-states are
getting but you've given the impression
that you're in it just for the money
aren't you that's and that is completely
that is completely not right president
your president energy himself just if I
can just say or you can have your
interview with yourself if I can just
say something firstly we've always said
to our citizens that we cannot and will
not look at towards the EU as a pot of
money that the that the better quality
of life the jobs better salaries need to
come from ourselves and the strength of
our economy that we want to be part of
the EU because he is a peace project and
we have shared values with the EU so if
that's true why did president voltage
three years ago when he was prime
minister make it clear when he told a
meeting in Tirana we are fed up with
seminars we need some money from the EU
funds then you'll see the smiles on our
faces that would be a clear indication
that he was simply after the money I
would say that you took out that
statement if it's correct and though I
do not remember that it is the context
if anything president voltage as the
Prime Minister repeatedly said EU is not
a pot of money for us we need to take
off take care of our own economy our
jobs our infrastructure the EU is a
different goal for Serbia now whether
we're going to be ready by 2025 to join
the EU is another question
and I think if you ask me if the EU said
you can join tomorrow I'd say no because
we're not ready which would which would
mean that again we get an enlargement in
which Serbia would be worse off and
Europe would be worse because I am more
interested in the reforms themselves
when it comes when it comes to Kosovo
Prime Minister you keep raising the bar
don't you you now say that any final
deal will have to be comprehensive it
will have to include among other things
Human Rights minority rights economic
cooperation learning each other's
language and cultural heritage you said
all this in a recent how is that raising
the bar it's going to take a long time
20 years at least why should the EU wait
around for that who says that
EU will wait around for that if it takes
20 years obviously we won't join the EU
who says that you will wait around who's
asking the EU to wait you are you
continuing with your membership
application aren't you
but of course so you want it to wait
around but of course because we want to
become members of the EU but I'm more
interested in the reforms once we
implement the reforms the EU will come
as a natural consequence of these
reforms if they want to waitron that's
fine if they don't want to wait around
that's also fine - yeah that will not
change you don't point out mine whether
they wait around on that will not change
Serbian policies a little bit we are
what we are doing in terms of the
reforms we are doing first and foremost
because of our own citizens and our
businesses for the quality of life of
citizens in Serbia ok well let's talk
about let me just let me just tell you
in detail let me just tell you what the
EU is for us firstly the reforms on our
EU accession path mean that we have
strong stable economy that we have we
implemented structural reforms that will
lead to strong stable economy what about
my rights and press freedom things what
about you let me finish I'll come to
that the second pillar is efficient
transparent public in public
administration the
peeler is the rule of law more stronger
more independent but also more efficient
and more accountable judiciary's talk
about press freedom one of the most
glaring failures of your government has
been refusal to protect freedom of
speech in February the Council of
Europe's Human Rights Commissioner said
the atmosphere in which journalists work
in Serbia appears to have deteriorated
quite seriously especially with the
smear campaigns against journalists with
some politicians calling them traitors
foreign agents and mercenaries you have
denied that any of this is the case but
Europe isn't buying your denials is it
well firstly I see that there is a
freedom of media in Serbia
I see no smear campaign I see criticism
of the president of myself of the
government every single day in the media
as it should be what about the
supposedly democratic society Prime
Minister let me give you an example
Alexander Martino the senior official of
your ruling progressive party he labeled
the head of the independent journalists
association of voivode inner an enemy of
Serbia because he'd made critical
comments about the authorities is that
acceptable I'm not saying that it's
acceptable for your sake it doesn't
happen well for one thing I'm saying
that there is a media freedoms in Serbia
I'm saying that there is media saying
the atmosphere in which journalists work
in Serbia appears to have deteriorated
quite seriously that's of these smear
absolutely agree with that
in Serbia who makes it up listen in
Serbia about 10 years ago or a little
bit over the over that when we actually
had a democratically democratically
oriented political party in power the
members of the ruling coalition kicked
physically kicked journalists the the
the anti-corruption Council said that
media is completely politically
influenced I think we have a lot to deal
with in Serbia and we are dealing with
it and I think this is
is improving it's by no means is by no
means worse than it was possible last
month an official from the security
information agency the BIA Marco para
zannowich
said the greatest threat to Serbia are
the foreign agents working in media
non-governmental agencies and opposition
parties it's an easy smear isn't it talk
about foreign agents in the media when
you have no evidence
for that what it is absolutely
ridiculous to quote one public servant
at the conference where the president of
Serbia talked about threats and I talked
about threats and you have the present
in the prime minister talking about
about threats which is migration
terrorism cyber security and Kosovo and
Metohija and no one is quoting that the
actual official policy of Serbia has
never ever said so you think this is all
taken out of context I think that you
had two of the highest official of
Serbia saying what the threats are and
and everyone disregarding this just so
that someone can take words of one
single public servant Prime Minister in
fact was a case in its latest report in
April the European Commission said the
fact that no progress had been made to
safeguard freedom of expression was a
matter of increasing concern that was in
April Serbian authorities said the
Commission need to provide active
support to independent bodies human
rights defenders and independent
journalists and promptly react to and
publicly condemned the threats against
them so why don't you do what the
Commission asked you to done exactly the
thing that the Commission asked me to do
it but they say you haven't let's see
let's see the the upcoming report thank
you for that question actually in fact
as the Prime Minister I sat down with
all the media representatives talk to
them about how what we can do to come up
with a credible media strategy they've
asked me for me personally
to run this the working group are
actually in my cabinet in my team and
know under the Ministry of Culture and
information that we have the working
group to work on the media strategy this
is exactly what we're doing right now
with the support of the European
Commission that is the European
delegation in Serbia the Konrad Adenauer
Steve Tong the OSCE and the region
embassy in Serbia okay and this and also
the getting through to Europe and
information where we see improvements
there as well also of course really
because we've in the me because I was
not going well I there is it going well
I know it's going really well
really sure I'll tell you also the media
representatives are that we have a
coordination body also under my cabinet
as the Prime Minister which will in
parallel with media strategy work on
resolving ad hoc issues that media have
in Serbia we've agreed to that as well
we are doing that they meet once a month
and are already resolving issues if you
want to you know I was my government is
the first government to actually
implement the open data policy we have
we are doing that together we have
adopted the Parliament has adopted law
the law only government which makes
opening data in Serbia I understand that
earlier this year the it seems to me
that you do understand I understand what
you were saying but I the EU disagrees
with it the status that the Council of
Europe and their human rights
commissioner who complained in his
report earlier this year that things
with regard to access to information are
not going well the government is not
implementing the recommendations of the
Commissioner for information of public
importance and the Parliament is not
discussing his reports you want to
continue down this road because they're
not buying your denials of this are they
I'm not saying that these are denials
there is so much work to be done and I
saying said I said yesterday at the
conference of Konrad Adenauer stiff them
I think if we look at our EU integration
in three key pillars economy public
administration rule of law by far the
most was done in the economy I would say
in terms of structural reforms
eighty-five percent of the job has been
done which is shown in the numbers that
Serbia has right now our GDP growth in
this year was four point five percent
our unemployment huffed our we are the
world leaders in FDI attraction in terms
of public administration reform public
probably fifty percent of the job has
done still a long way to go in terms of
the rule of law thirty percent has been
done so we have a long long way to go
you have a long way to go on the issue
of war crimes as well where the EU is
still not satisfied with your
performance well you you is certainly
not 100 percent satisfied we are less
than 100 I would say that Serbia by far
is the best case example in the region
of how to deal with the war crimes
really by January 2016 in May 2017
Serbia had no formally appointed war
crimes prosecutor for 17 months and that
was that was a way of showing your
willingness to deal with this and not
just that you can you can absolutely not
disregard everything that Serbia has
been doing with respect to the war
crimes since 2000 since in the last 18
years
okay most of all other countries
enduring according to the great action
plan for chapter 23 of the Yuri you
application five additional deputy
prosecutor should have been appointed by
the end of 2017 why weren't they if
you're doing everything you need to do
well to be honest I thought I don't know
the answer to that question but we've
appointed them now and I have to say
that you know you have you know
priorities first and Serbia literally
four years ago was three months away
from bank bankruptcy which goes to say
that we really had
focus all of our effort all of our
strength on very difficult very
unpopular economic reforms you cannot do
everything at the same time so far
there's been no indictments against
senior military or police officials for
war crimes there are currently 15 cases
ongoing the majority involved low
ranking military or police defendants
what's the deal the higher-ups the
senior officers get away with it and the
lower ones take the prosecution's is
that it I dunno I do not agree with you
and again I think that Serbia has done
by far the most still you know still
there is a job to be done but I think
that Serbia and I am absolutely proud
with how Serbia has handled our issues
from the past are you are you proud of
the trend in Serbia that the EU points
to to see former war criminals as heroes
or role models do you subscribe to that
no I do not I do not I I think that you
know we see in other countries in the
region the the war criminals actually or
or indicted war criminals actually have
official roles as advisors to the
presidents or in the government you know
we have we see some being even the Prime
Minister's but in Serbia you do not have
those kind of things you have Vladimir
lazarevich for instance convicted for
crimes against ethnic Albanians in
Kosovo the appointed lecturer at the
Serbian military academy not true he was
convicted he served his sentence he was
released he is in Serbia now he was one
time lecture guest lecture at the
Military Academy on if I'm not if I'm
not mistaken on what was the combat a
during the NATO bombing campaign over
Serbia so he's not appointed the lecture
at the military Nicholas a novice
convicted of similar acts later
reappointed to his own position as a
member of the Executive Council of the
Serbian Socialist Party happy with that
is Serbian Socialist Party has nothing
to do with the government is nothing to
do with the official functions your
handle
rehabilitated into public life these
people these what what do you want me to
do with these people if they were
convicted serve their sentence to you
and and released do you want us to lock
them up in Serbia so they can not show
their faces I'll just sit in Parliament
like VoiceLive special for instance what
made a voice long shot should I remain
who says he's proud of all the war
crimes and crimes against humanity that
were reminding I will remind you and
while talking about the rule of law a
voice of session handed himself to the
Hague Tribunal voluntarily had in 13
years 13 years trial is that what you
call rule of law and was then acquitted
came back to Serbia and then I agree on
was overturned this year it was
overturned it was overturned but 13 year
sentence by industry because of times of
course okay of course they still hold
him at least three years of his life
nemanja Stepanovitch nemanja Stepanovich
from the center for humanitarian law in
Belgrade Serbia has not moved an inch
from the time when the wars were being
fought in the 1990s as one after another
war criminals are released and give us
given a ceremonial reception by the
government on their return they're being
ushered back into public institutions he
said I'm just telling you that that's
not true he doesn't know what he's
talking about I disagree with him so and
and to say that Serbia hasn't done
anything he's unbelievable I didn't say
I have done anything enough according to
the EU hasn't done enough okay
perhaps we can do more and and and we
will to ensure the rule of law in Serbia
and to and and to deal with the past and
turn towards the future Serbia will do
its part but I would actually caution
everyone
not to really look at serbia alone but
to also look at what other countries in
the region are doing does doing what's
expected of it for you include
acknowledging that the massacre at
cerebra needs in 1995 was genocide you
were asked in May last year by the
Council of Ministers a Council of Europe
to recognize revenues as genocide you've
never done that are you prepared to do
that no I do not think that the terrible
crime massacre in straberry sir was a
genocide you must know that unless you
take the step the chances of you joining
European Union a very slim aren't they I
know I don't know that we because it was
a hideous crime it was a war crime I am
NOT happy because of it it wasn't done
in the name of Serbian people and
Serbian kid no sir Serbs cannot be
collectively be blamed for what happened
there two courts the International
Criminal Tribunal Tribunal for the
former Yugoslavia and the International
Court of Justice both ruled that it was
genocide okay and you won't accept it
I do not think it was a genocide you're
rewriting history aren't you trying to
rewrite history I do not think it was a
genocide I think it was but let me just
say it seems like you know I'm you know
I think it was it was a terrible
terrible crime but genocide is basically
when you are genocide is when you're you
know the killing the entire population
the women children and this was not that
case in 2004 the presiding judge at the
Criminal Tribunal for the former
Yugoslavia said by seeking to eliminate
a part of the Bosnian Muslims the
Bosnian Serb forces committed genocide
they targeted for extinction the 40,000
Bosnian Muslims living in Srebrenica a
group which was emblematic of the
Bosnian Muslims in general that's why it
was labeled genocide
okay and if you if you if you can't
accept it why should unaccepting it it
was a terrible crime serbia delivered
the person who was charged with let that
more crime we've delivered that person
she was in trial he's in jail now but
you won't accept the step which the
council of europe asks you to accept
that it was a janitor yeah i'm telling
you it was that's your red line is it
I'm telling you you're never gonna do it
I told you my answer
Prime Minister I know from the bridge
thank you very much for you know complex
oh thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]